welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Robert Trager Robert maybe you
want to start by introducing yourself to
our audience
oh sure uh well thanks so much guys um
so glad to to be with you I'm Robert
Trager I am a social scientist I have
for many years been at UCLA where I was
a professor and I'm recently moving from
there to Oxford where I will co-direct
uh the uh Oxford Martin AI governance
initiative
and I guess I'll have a position at the
blavatnik school and I'm also the
international governance lead at the
center for the governance of AI which is
also based in in Oxford so that's me
that's perfect so it sounds like you
know a lot about AI governance which is
exactly what we're gonna talk about
today so um what is it that we're trying
to achieve with with AI governance what
are what risks are we most afraid of
what risks are we most afraid of that
what a good what an interesting first
question
um there's so many things uh to to be
worried about uh and and they're
different ways of categorizing risks
so one way that people sometimes do it
is into the three buckets of misuse
risks accident risks and structural
risks and I think that is pretty a
pretty sensible way to to think about it
and there are all kinds of misuse risks
right
this technology is democratizing the
ability to do things in general
so some of those things are are misuses
um
and it's also potentially supercharging
the well other domains of Science and
that presents some risks
in itself because for instance if
biology is more
effective at doing things then it can be
more effective at doing some things that
are harmful
and so there so there's some risks
associated with that of course there are
to go along with of course all of the
the positive aspects of
of the technology and extraordinary
things that it can do for the world so
two examples that I've heard thrown
around is the possibility of creating an
engineered virus to potentially create a
pandemic that's that's worse than than
covid-19 and the possibility of cyber
attacks helped by these Advanced AI
capabilities do you think those would be
the two kind of top priorities to
prevent oh gosh top priority is really
it's actually a really tough question uh
I think that those are important
priorities I I wouldn't want to say they
were the only priorities or or even the
top priorities but I I do think that
um those are some examples of things
that progress even near-term progress in
a in AI
can can really democratize the ability
to do things in those areas and so there
are certainly things that we ought to be
worried about so when we talk about
democratizing these abilities one one
criticism that I've heard here is that
well what's the difference between just
searching with a search engine and
finding this information
as opposed to getting it through perhaps
a language model or gaining knowledge
about biological weapons through one of
these AIS the the threats we're worried
about how are they different from
whatever information people can find
online already now well I don't think we
want to exaggerate the the threats of uh
sort of the systems that exist today
also I think people are right you know I
remember talking to
um some of the people who were doing
some red teaming on on some recent
systems and they were coming from the
National Security establishment and
their view it was basically you know
these things are making things up and
they're making things up from a
knowledge base that is all not
classified information and so how
dangerous can they really be and I think
you know that's that's important to to
recognize those those bounds on what
current systems can do so I think
there's a question about what the next
Generations of systems will be able to
do certainly but even when it comes to
current systems I mean you use this
cyber example uh being able to write
code is very powerful and um and so when
you have people who not who now don't
actually have to take a course in coding
or many courses encoding in order to do
something but presumably can convince a
language model to do it for them that
can be much easier and and mean that a
much wider section of the public can
think about doing those things so that's
what we mean by democratizing I think
there are some risks very significant
ones along those lines in in BIO and
cyber that you mentioned and and a whole
host of of other things and you know
while we're talking about these things
probably we shouldn't think we shouldn't
forget about social justice also and
access to the technology and and having
a voice that is
these Technologies are affecting
everyone so everyone deserves a voice in
what happens how they're governed how
they evolve
um and I don't think we're we're there
right now so really there's a lot of
work to be done on the governance front
and also we should keep in mind how
quickly these Technologies are improving
so we might find ourselves continually
surprised by new capabilities that we
hadn't uh predicted beforehand and so
just because something isn't possible
right now maybe it's possible in six
months or in two years or whatever
that's a great point I mean people I
think when they're thinking about for
instance what should be released to the
public what technology should be
classified and not often they think well
is it dangerous today
but if there are 10 steps
that are involved in making a technology
that that's dangerous and you release
information about the first nine of them
well then you've really proliferated the
technology and we've made mistakes about
that in the past you know in the past we
have uh you know some of the techniques
for instance for diffusing uh
uranium we thought well these techniques
aren't going to work but those may work
so we classified one set and and not the
other set but it turned out to be the
reverse and as a result some of those
techniques are much more widely
dispersed in in the world than they
otherwise would be
um so I think you know these these
Downstream effects are are extremely
important I totally agree with you and
exactly when it comes to AI what can be
built on top of current day systems even
just that Beyond you know what's the
next iteration of of the large language
models or something like that but what
can be built and done with current
systems with different forms of access
we don't know the answer to that
question so uh yeah there's a there's a
whole range of risks as you point out
yeah even if we even if we stopped now
and didn't train any larger language
models and we would still have a lot to
explore about the capabilities of a
system like tpt4 for example
um I I think we haven't exhausted what
it what the what this system can do even
even if we
we're just talking about implementing it
in different ways or trying to get it to
do new things
yeah I think that's right I mean I like
the idea
that others have talked about that we
could think of a language model as kind
of uh the system one in the sense of
condiment system one and system two in
the brain I like that idea it seems sort
of right to me and and obviously in the
brain there are all these systems that
are kind of built on top of of other
systems and I think it's the same we
don't really understand how those
systems work in the brain and we don't
understand how they work in large
language models and the sorts of
interpretability that we have are
several Generations behind in terms of
trying to to figure out how these models
are are working that's absolutely right
it's it's uh even the current systems
are a sort of Frontier to be
investigated in terms of understanding
them yeah if we return to the question
of governance AI governance for for a
moment I think one important place to
start is to talk about the incentives
involved just because institutions
respond to incentives so when when you
look over the landscape of government
and companies what do you see as the
incentives for for the various
governments involved and for the various
companies involved well motives are
mixed of course they are and there are
lots of individuals who want to do the
right thing out there uh and it's often
fascinating to watch them be a part of
an organization that has an
organizational imperative so an
individual might have all sorts of ideas
be they in a government or in a company
and they want to do uh one thing but
then there's there's an organization
that has an incentive to let's say
maintain its reputation or there's just
a range of institutional incentives that
make it hard for I think individuals to
always do the things that they want to
do but the organizations of course they
have mixed motives that's what makes it
such an interesting and complicated
strategic landscape and in mixed motives
by the way are exactly the sort of thing
that are hard for for AI strategic
systems to deal with right we have
superhuman systems that deal with the
two-person zero-sum case but when we're
talking about a complex environment
which involves both uh incentives to
cooperate and incentives to compete
um we don't really have superhuman at
least when there are multiple actors in
that in that case so you know those are
those are the complicated cases and
that's the world that we're in when it
comes to the to governments and uh when
it comes to the governments and the and
and all of the labs in the area is it
one account I've heard is just that both
governments and companies are
incentivized to just rush ahead for
companies it's about gaining market
share for governments it's about gaining
kind of geopolitical power but isn't
there another incentive to through I
mean for for companies to create
products that they can actually sell
these products must be at least somewhat
safe for the consumer no no company is
interested in in selling a self-driving
car that that kills the the driver
um and and for for governments I mean
there's there's the there's a question
of international reputation and if you
if you have accidents with your AI
systems that might cause embarrassment
in my uh weaken your alliances with your
with your allies and so on I think that
you're right about the the question of
of mixed motives here but which
incentives do you think are strongest
yeah I think you're absolutely right
that there are these uh incentives
against allowing regulatory backlash for
instance uh we really have seen that in
other Industries like most famously the
nuclear industry uh after Fukushima for
instance the the industry experienced
and Chernobyl the industry experienced a
huge contraction
so Industries have an incentive to avoid
that some of the um self-regulation on
the part of companies is them being
preemptive and worried a bit about the
regulation that's coming and therefore
regulating regulating themselves so I
think I think on the one hand that
that's right that that companies are
worried about those things on the other
hand they have these other incentives
also as you point out to be first to
Market and to race quickly and
um which of those went out in a
particular case is I think is in a way
unknown
but I think it's also fair to say that
um industry players
and countries when they're competing
with other countries they have some
incentives which are different from the
broad societal incentives I don't think
we can get away from that even though
they have some
incentives that are that push them in
the in the direction that maybe we as
society would would want to push them in
the sense of well they're worried about
a regulatory backlash that's great
they're worried about regulatory
backlash I want them to be worried about
it you know they're worried about bad
regulation from governments and
therefore they're self-regulating I love
that you know bad the potential of bad
regulation from governments is good in
this case uh so those things those
things are great on the other hand
I don't think we can rely there on
incentives being totally aligned because
they won't be they're still private
incentives that these countries or
institutions or even in some cases
individuals have that are different from
the general interest even though they
have some things that push them in the
in the way that we would want them to be
pushed you've written about regulation
and the need for international AI
governance regulations so perhaps we
could talk about why AI governance why
does this regulation have to be
International in order to work I think
there's some questions that we don't
fully know the answer to and in order to
figure out
whether we really need
lots of international governance or just
some International governance so I think
there's a set of questions that we can
start to ask ourselves to figure out
what sorts of international governance
are are really important but I guess
what I would say is if
we're not
thinking about International governance
at the very least
we are not addressing some buckets of
risk
so just to give you an example and maybe
we'll get to this later but you know one
of the questions that we can ask
ourselves is
um can we just regulate by controlling
some uh let's say compute Supply chains
among a small set of of allies
and you know maybe that can mitigate
quite a lot of risks I think that's a
possibility
but
I don't think it's a certainty
because for instance it might be the
case that existing compute that's out
there
can
produce quite a lot of risk already and
these things are are still debated you
know so even if you don't for instance
have access to the latest AI data center
chips
you might be able to have some technical
workarounds
that allow you to use non-state of the
art chips many more of them may be
somewhat more slowly but nevertheless
use that compute that you as an actor
have access to to do all sorts of things
so we we don't really know the answer to
that kind of question where lots of
risks are going to come from and then
there's all kinds of related questions
we we don't know the answer to we don't
know the answer to whether for instance
AI systems are going to be able to
protect against other AI systems so if
the answer is yes then that's great you
know then you you need less
International governance and and that's
like one problem or set of problems that
we don't have to worry about but I would
say that um I don't think I would bet in
that direction at the very least they're
going to be some real trade-offs if
that's the direction that we're going in
and so I think when we when we think
about International governance it's it's
a question of addressing some of the
risks that we can address through some
feasible strategies that that I think we
have rather than relying on other
strategies that are are somewhat tenuous
and might work but we really don't have
good reason to think that we're living
in those worlds
yeah so are there types or categories of
risks that International regulation is
particularly well suited to solve or to
alleviate for us
that International in particular is well
suited to alleviate yeah that's an
interesting question so I think that
civilian governance is one area that we
can really make progress I think one of
the reasons why we throw up hurdles in
the way of international governance is
because we think about the difficulty of
trying to have arms control of some
variety and that it's not controversial
to say that that is is very difficult
and you know we don't have to look far
we can look for instance at the attempt
to regulate lethal autonomous weapons
you know more than a decade of attempt
to do that in the context of the CCW the
convention on certain Conventional
Weapons through the United Nations in
Geneva and I think that has been
effective in creating some norms and I
think that's important but on the other
hand the the advocates for regulation
they've really wanted positive law and
they haven't gotten that
and it probably is not a coincidence
that they haven't gotten that that is 10
years ago probably that outcome could
have been predicted so
Arms Control you know we can talk about
all sorts of analogies it's very
difficult
civilian governance
is I think the kind of thing that we
have some viable models of
and I personally along with some others
think that the models of things like the
international civilian Aviation
organization the international Maritime
organization the financial action task
force that these these models are are
good ones I don't have to go into that
more but that gets into some detail yeah
so when you say civilian AI You're
simply talking about non-military AI is
that correct yeah I think we you know we
have a white paper that's coming out on
this topic and and we use a slightly
different definition but I think that
definition is fine for our purposes if
we begin regulating on a global scale
and have one set of regulations that
that apply to all of the world
does this prevent us from discovering
the best possible regulations so so my
worry here would be that we can't
experiment with different types of
regulations say that you have 200
countries each with their own regulation
and then you see you you monitor the
outcomes and then see what works best
that's that seems to be something we we
are shut out from doing if we have one
set of regulations for the entire world
if if we set aside the the issue of
whether that's even feasible and and
whether we would have time to make such
investigations and so on but uh
do you see if there's a problem with
applying one set of rules to to the
entire Globe oh we should not even
attempt absolutely should not attempt to
to apply one set of rules across all
domains of AI governance to the whole
world for instance Europe and China and
the US have different preferences over
privacy regulation and that's good they
should be allowed to have different
approaches societal values should be
reflected in National regulation
and um and we shouldn't attempt to quash
that on the other hand there probably
are some areas of I would characterize
them as minimal standards where we can
consense and we can agree and those are
probably the things that should be
internationalized I agree with you that
experimentation is important I I'm all
for empirical experimentation at other
times and places I've been I've thought
of myself as a theorist but being a
theorist I know the limits of theory and
I really appreciate the opportunity for
experimentation I think it would be good
here on the other hand it also depends
on the stakes we don't want to be
experimenting you can do inefficient
experimentation also so no we don't want
one-size-fits-all regulation we want to
agree on some minimal standards we want
to investigate whether those standards
are the right standards but in some
cases probably we don't want to have too
much experimentation also and so that
set of minimal standards would apply
globally and would be one size if it's
all in the sense but with room for
significant National variability within
that those kind of common standards I
think that's right I think there are
certain things that you wouldn't want
any country in the world
to
release a system that made it very easy
to do harms that other systems and
actors couldn't defend against right
that would be a pretty minimal standard
or you know people worry about agentic
Ai and if you have an AI which is power
seeking or something like that then that
would also be the sort of thing that you
would want to prevent any actor from
doing but you know within
those kind of basic limits I think it's
good for different societies to make
different choices am I understanding you
correctly that you're pessimistic about
getting a common set of rules for
military AI that's a really interesting
question I think there are some things
that I I don't think we can give up on
thinking about Arms Control not at all I
think there are lots of things to to
think about I just think that that is
maybe the second thing to think about
and civilian regulation because so much
of the development is already going on
within the private sector uh and and
it's an easier problem I think it's a
problem we should do first and maybe at
the same time we can be worried about
what we can do in terms of uh in terms
of the military side of things yeah
because if it seems to me that if we
leave out the military side of things we
might not have solved the problem at all
if we have a
dangerous AI systems in
U.S and China militaries then the
problem almost is is fully there why
would you start with the civilian side
and then try to move to the to the
military side well the main reason you
know is that it it's um what I think can
be done uh in the near term I think
there are so many challenges uh on the
military side one thing that is will at
some point maybe be available is a
non-proliferation regime with Norms of
use and you know that can deal with a
whole class of risks when it comes to
maybe not the countries that are
absolutely at the Forefront but but
other countries and any agreement like
that has to have almost certainly has to
have a development component too in in
order to get any traction as well as
just from the point of view of of
societal Justice there are things we can
do on the military side or there there
may be a non-proliferation regime with
some Norms of use although there are
specific challenges when it comes to
Norms of use with respect to AI because
for instance you you know when a bomb
goes off so you can say well we should
have a norm against that happening
because you know when it happens on the
other hand when a lethal autonomous
weapon is used it's hard to say if the
autonomous capabilities were actually
engaged and more broadly it is hard to
know if if AI has actually been engaged
and used so I think as a result that
means that it's difficult more difficult
potentially to develop Norms of use
and when we think about for instance
deterrence or mutually assured
destruction mutually sure destruction is
a contested term but I think we have an
idea about what we mean and there's a
popular idea about what we mean and that
and so we can just say that it's harder
to have that sort of deterrence
equilibrium when it is unsure when a
system was actually used and so it's
possible that we could really be in the
world of let's say Cyber Technology
where the actors estate actors are doing
all sorts of things to each other within
some limits but in terms of developing
the capabilities to do things they're
doing everything that they can and they
don't even try really to have agreements
to prevent each other from doing it
because they they don't see how they
could be sure that their adversaries
were actually complying with such an
agreement so it's possible that with
Advanced AI we'll be in a similar sort
of a world and that would mean it would
be very hard to have uh regulations
among major Powers but even then
I think there's the possibility for
non-proliferation regimes as I say with
a with a development component also yeah
and what exactly do you mean by by that
in this context in the context of AI
non-proliferation of of the AI systems
themselves so how exactly does it work
so AI is is often talked about in terms
of three parts the the data the
algorithms uh and the compute and I
think we can think about
non-proliferation of of all those parts
actually so there's some ideas that may
be uh in fact dangerous ideas
um you know just like we have
classification and the so-called born
secret Doctrine in nuclear policy we
might need to say that well some ideas
are are not the sort of things that
we're going to allow out into the
general public or allow uh to some uh
governments around the world so when
we're talking about Computing Hardware
it's easier for me to see how
non-proliferation would work you could
talk about Port controls yeah it's a
physical thing when you're talking about
data and algorithms it's it becomes more
difficult for me to see how that would
work as soon as something is online
uploaded somewhere
isn't it just out there would we
wouldn't we need kind of a
military-grade information security in
order to to secure a non-proliferation
of the algorithms and the data well I
think it's a huge topic sort of cyber
security and Labs I don't think we
should at all give up on that I think
it's uh it's incredibly important and uh
and we may need a military-grade
security there's a justifiable uh focus
on compute which you also reflect and I
agree with that but on the other hand we
don't really know if we're in a in a
world where doing dangerous things
requires lots of compute or or not we
actually don't know that yet for sure uh
and so I I don't think we should rule
out all the other things that we might
have to do uh if we're if we're in the
other world and no matter what world
we're in I think you know there's
certain
ideas and capabilities that probably we
don't want being generally available and
so you know if you're talking about
securing systems against a determined
State adversary that's one thing if on
the other hand you're talking about
securing information against uh general
knowledge or something like that that's
something else and we should probably be
investigating both of those Avenues yeah
and also these three components can be
traded off against each other so if we
had a strict limit on compute we
companies might be able to invest
heavily in algorithms or in data
collection and and management and and
thereby still uh make a lot of progress
and in that situation you might even
have a what's called a hardware overhang
so that you're you're building up your
algorithm or you're improving your
algorithms and you're improving the way
you you construct your your training
data such that when the hardware becomes
cheap enough or if the hardware improves
you can make significant gains in in a
quick amount of power in a pretty fast
what we're trying to do here is to think
about in advance what how we might
govern AI and just if you look at the
Historical track record you you were
talking about
um autonomous weapons
uh this is this is something that's
pretty difficult to do what we attempted
to do with autonomous weapons was to
think in advance okay this is a
technology that might become dangerous
in the future let's think about how to
regulate it now before it it's as
dangerous as we feared might become how
how would you rate our track record here
of of trying to trying to think
something through in advance and
regulate it oh what's our track record
across Technologies that's an
interesting question well there's
something called the calling calling
Ridge dilemma I always forget if it's a
ridge or wood but it's a ridge calling
Ridge dilemma
um which says that time when you are
able to effectively regulate as early on
in a Technologies life cycle but the
time when you actually know what
regulation would be good you know that
comes only later and um actually he he
thought that there was just simply no
way to know what the right regulations
would be early on so he he thought we
had to deal with it some other way but I
I think that what we're realizing now is
that
um given the extraordinarily increasing
capabilities of Technology we have no
choice but to do anticipatory regulation
because it could end up being the case
that the next version of whatever
technology has such an impact that um
that we just if we didn't prepare for it
we you know that we'd be derelict
so I think uh you're absolutely right
that um that that we need to do that now
did we did we have do we have a good
track record
um no no not really uh such a great
track record of um of thinking about
technological regulation uh in advance
yeah so I think on the in the case of
Civilian technology governance we have
lots of examples of success stories you
know including for powerful Technologies
uh airplanes and and boats and lots of
other things are very powerful
Technologies and and we managed to
regulate them on the other hand on the
on the arms control side when we think
about
nuclear and biotechnologies I would say
we haven't really been that successful
the nuclear analogy is an interesting
one you know there was an attempt of
course the Atchison lillianthal plan and
and then the Baruch uh plan there was an
attempt to really internationalize the
technology and in fact to to create a
sort of international Monopoly over uh
nuclear the nuclear industry the entire
nuclear industry and of course that that
didn't succeed there's a question about
whether it would have been a good thing
if it had succeeded but but that sort of
anticipatory governance wasn't
particularly successful in that case or
we might think about the biological
weapons convention I mean that's an
interesting one which I think really
shows us how difficult arms control is
uh in in some ways paradoxically because
the biological weapons convention is a
case where
you know many countries in the world
came together and
prevented and signed a treaty in which
they agreed not to develop not to
stockpile not to use
this technology
but they didn't have any verification
means they didn't worry about that
really
and it turns out that there were
violations and not just little
violations but huge violations of this
convention and the Soviet Union had tens
of thousands of people working on
biological
weapons so
I think that
these sorts of agreements in many cases
they have done some important things the
biological weapons convention probably
made it harder for actors around the
world to develop biological weapons it
probably had therefore a
non-proliferation effect
but
it didn't do
the letter of what it set out to do
which was prevent any actor in the world
from developing these sorts of weapons
so this question about the track record
that we have I think is a is a
fascinating one I would say we have some
success stories we don't we have fewer
success stories about
anticipatory governance
in the case of
um regulating military one of the
interesting things is that in a way
we're successful about being
anticipatory in a limited way you know
if you think about the space treaty or
the ABM Treaty for instance these were
things that were regulating Technologies
before they really existed but the very
fact that
they were anticipatory in this sense is
perhaps what allowed the treaties to
happen in the first place and in for
instance in the case of ABM you might
say that as the it looked more and more
like the technology was becoming real
the Treaty of course
um went away
uh so I'm not sure we can quite count
that as a success of anticipatory
regulation so maybe we could have gotten
countries to sign on AI regulation in
1960 for example because there would
have been no perceived cause to doing so
exactly but but then would it have done
any good because then once the
technology evolved such that it was
meaningful they may have dropped out
yeah I think there's some other examples
of that and and I think it's an
important uh caveat when we're
accounting sort of successes and
failures of attempts to regulate
technology we talk about incentives
before and I think we should touch upon
some of the potential negative
incentives of international regulation
so one thing I thought about was whether
just rumors of international regulation
could incentivize countries or companies
within countries to be less transparent
about what they're developing so would
it be the case that they publish less
and they they don't announce their their
breakthroughs because well if
if they don't announce anything that's
that seems powerful then they might be
able to delay regulation do you think
that's plausible and that's that's uh
this potential downside yeah so I think
those are exactly the right worries to
have on the one hand and I think we have
examples of that from other Industries
um so two that I that I really like are
I don't know that I like them but I
think they're very interesting and
telling from the oil industry in the
tobacco industry because in these cases
you had the potential for liability
and firms knew that maybe they could be
liable for some of the things that they
were doing and so in some cases that
meant that their view was well better
not to know if there are negative
consequences to what we're doing and
they actually you know fire people as a
result they they try to make sure that
they don't have the ability to to know
things
um and I think that is a is a real
danger there may even have been some
cases of that already in the AI industry
I mean it's speculative
um and I don't want to name names but I
think that there is at least one case
where it sort of really looked that way
so uh so I think I think regulation can
do harm that is a danger some of the
other specific dangers that you
mentioned like driving activities
somewhere else are exactly the sort of
thing that I think countries will be
wary of uh and have been wary of on the
other hand this is also an argument for
international regulation right it's
precisely a case where you're worried
about regulatory standards having a
so-called race to the bottom or maybe a
race maybe it doesn't get all the way to
the bottom but it goes down anyway and
there's kind of corner cutting all
around
and that is the kind of thing that you
want to prevent with an International
International standard and that's
exactly what international standards can
do sometimes right because the actors
are they none of the actors necessarily
want to regulate themselves to the
degree that that is optimal but they're
willing to regulate themselves because
they get out of the bargain that
everybody else gets regulated to and
they really are happy with that
so um so I do think that these things
are a worry and what we have to be
thinking about but they're also the
reason why we need to do it let's talk a
bit about the security dilemma and and
AI perhaps let's you could start by
explaining what the security dilemma is
I'm particularly interested in how it
how it um applies to the situation
between China and the US
yeah so the security dilemma is a case
where actions taken by one actor to make
itself more safe are making other actors
less safe and
um absolutely I think we we see that in
the case of AI one of the interesting
things with AI is that it's maybe harder
to see the actions that other actors are
or are not taking
um that is say development is maybe even
harder to see than it is in other areas
and so in some ways you know you might
not have the kind of spirals where one
actor says oh I see what you're doing
the other actor says oh yeah I see what
you're doing too and they kind of
Ratchet up but on the other hand they
can have a kind of spiral in the mind if
you will and they haven't they have an
idea about what others are doing there's
actually some attempts to to model this
formally uh there was
um Stuart Armstrong and uh and some
others thought about this with their
racing to the precipice paper and then
there have been some recent papers that
that I've been involved with
um including one by Nicholas Emery shoe
that thinks about exactly these kinds of
issues is it better for the actors to
know what each other are doing or to not
know and be able to guess and um and
well they somewhat uh less dramatic
answer is that it depends it's not it's
not always good to know it's not always
good um good not to know in expectation
yeah just to take a non-ai example of
the security dilemma we could talk about
the situation surrounding Taiwan where
one account is that the US is trying to
encircle uh and and and arm various
Islands surrounding Taiwan and China
perceives this as a as a threat to their
security then they respond by beefing up
security which the the U.S perceives as
an aggression and so on and that is that
is kind of the spiraling down uh uh
dynamics of the security at dilemma and
and the question is then whether AI as a
technology changes this dilemma is it as
you mentioned AI is less less obviously
visible you can't necessarily see it
with satellite technology it seems it
seems to me that it would be better if
China wasn't so worried about what the
US was doing with AI and the reverse
would also be the case is that the U.S
wasn't so worried about how China was
was still doing with with AI progress I
think it would be much better if they
weren't worried and there's a question
about how to make them not worried and
sometimes having information makes you
more worried and sometimes it makes you
makes you less worried one thing that
information pretty much always does is
allow for agreements because information
is something that you can condition on
and so for instance if you know what the
other side is doing you can say okay
well we won't do it either if if you
don't do it and that can lead to to an
agreement as long as doing that thing
isn't
um neither side has such an incentive to
do it in the short term then you can
have these kinds of punishment
strategies through through agreements
and so in that sense information is good
but but in in other senses if they know
exactly what each other are doing and
maybe they then realize that okay we're
really close in some Dimension that
we're being just a little bit ahead is
important so those are the kind of cases
where very often although not all ways
having more information can be can be
bad because that then allows them to
engage in these really
um
really sort of negative outcome races
where they're competing over a very fine
leads that they that they each might
have or seek to have
yeah so the U.S and Taiwan is a good
example of a security dilemma
potentially because for instance the U.S
could support Taiwan and its support and
the more clear its support is the more
threatening that might be to Chinese
interests and in fact that might even
precipitate a conflict that is if the
U.S were to come and say that it was
giving absolutely its full support
behind Taiwanese Independence that might
actually precipitate a conflict which uh
you know there are funny Dynamics here
where
doing that on the by by the us could be
credible precisely because it's
precipitating a conflict potentially but
on the other hand you might not want to
precipitate a conflict yeah so the sides
have this this kind of dilemma which is
why we call it a security dilemma uh in
terms of doing things that seem to make
them more secure but might ratchet up
the conflict and I think Taiwan is a
place where where we see that and maybe
you've brought it up because it's also a
place that is so critical to AI Supply
chains and why is it that it's so
critical to AI Supply chains well in
terms of the high-end chips the
Fabricators are mostly based in Taiwan
so I think upwards of 90 percent of The
Cutting Edge AI chips are actually
coming from Taiwan this nationalist
Target of uh the the Chinese government
maybe the most important and certainly
one of the most important goals of the
the Chinese Communist party is
reunification with Taiwan so throwing
all of this into the AI mix yeah if you
wanted to set up the world for conflict
you couldn't have done much better than
to put a lot of very valuable to your
production on on Taiwan I think yes I
think that's right as if we as if there
wasn't uh enough reason to have conflict
over Taiwan already and we in fact have
had conflicts over Taiwan already it
seems like in the future
uh the some part of the balance of power
in the world could be related to
activities on Taiwan and so yet another
reason potentially for conflict there so
if we talk about the security dilemma
from the perspective of AI and and if
you allow me to speculate a little bit
here is it at all plausible that
countries might begin hiding their AI
capabilities potentially so that they
can they can use their Advanced AI to
develop even more advanced Ai and gain a
kind of a decisive strategic advantage
over over another country is it
plausible that they will hide what could
amount to military capabilities
yeah yes of course of course they
they've always tried to hide those
things and you know when we think back
to projects like the Manhattan Project
they have tried to hide in and we should
expect them to continue to to try to
hide those things and some really large
scale projects are hard to hide
but actually in this area there's
probably quite a lot that can be done
without it being at least easy to detect
although you can be sure that
intelligence services are working on
detecting it and so it wouldn't be a
situation like the the space race in in
the Cold War where you had superpowers
trying to to Showcase their their
abilities and their power I could see it
going both ways in a sense yeah
absolutely and they they'll want to
showcase certain things uh absolutely
and and sometimes they will feel like
they have a kind of social status
interest in showcasing uh as in Sputnik
you know look at this this thing we can
launch it right over your head uh so
there's no doubt that um that sometimes
they will contemplate doing that but
there's also the the other incentives
and I think it's it's hard to know which
of those incentives will win out in
particular cases that's a fascinating
social science question because I think
it's very interesting any graduate
students out there who would like to
investigate that I think it would be a
great question we should chat yeah okay
you can I'll put your your email in the
in the description and people can
contact you if they're interested okay
you have a a chapter in a in a
forthcoming textbook uh where you sketch
out four kind of crucial considerations
surrounding AI governance and I think it
will be fruitful for for us to to kind
of run through them and then and get
your thoughts the first of your
questions that you actually mentioned
previously is whether AI can defend
against uh other AI so so is is AI able
to protect you from from the enemy's AI
in a sense can can one country use their
AI to protect themselves from from
another country's AI this is related to
kind of a defense offense balance and so
on so maybe you could explain that
concept also well so I haven't um I
haven't seen the the Oppenheimer movie
yet oddly I keep being prevented I'm
sure I'll see it soon but I understand
there's a scene which is which is also
one that I think people are familiar
with from the historical record where
Oppenheimer is testifying before
committee and he is asked in the early
days of uh of a nuclear period he's
asked what is the technological solution
to prevent somebody from smuggling a
bomb into New York Harbor in a crate
and his answer is a screwdriver
which is to say there isn't a technical
solution to that problem we need a a
social solution yeah so can
technological developments defend us
from
technology well sometimes they can but
sometimes it seems like they they
probably can't right so and this gets to
lots of interesting questions about for
instance open sourcing so we can ask
ourselves you know uh would open
sourcing some of AI technology be
helpful or harmful and the answer is
probably both to some degree but how
does it net out and there are areas
where we have open source and in fact in
the Cyber area there's some things that
have been open source that have been
worked on by whole communities of people
who have made them more made those
systems more robust and that's been
effective but if we were to open source
uh you know nuclear weapons ideas or the
science behind it would that actually
then lead to defenses against nuclear
weapons I think we can be skeptical
there so sometimes it does and and
sometimes some times it doesn't you
mentioned I guess I should say the
offense defense balance is this idea
well it actually it's quite fraud
exactly how you define it but it may be
that when countries are fighting sort of
being on the offense is advantaged and
so sort of being the first mover is
advantaged or it may be that the reverse
is true that it's good to sort of wait
for the adversary to come to you or
something like that and so that's a
strategic parameter which is is going to
affect the incentives that countries
have to get into conflicts uh in the in
the age of AI potentially as as well do
you think it makes sense to talk about
weapons having specific balances between
their defensive and offensive
capabilities so perhaps we could claim
that nuclear weapons are more offensive
are better than offense than they are at
defense for example uh it's funny
because people often say the opposite
about nuclear weapons that that actually
even though it seems like as you say
they're better at offense in fact the
result of them is that you have mutually
assured destruction and so they lead to
this defense dominant sort of world so I
do think that that points out that these
things are in in some sense hard to be
rigorous about or at least you know
people haven't come up with the way of
of sort of ex-anti uh thinking about a
weapon system and and really effectively
coding whether it is offense or defense
dominant on the other hand I I think
it's kind of a useful idea that helps us
to think about what sort of world we're
likely to be living in so for instance
you might think that a world that's more
offense dominant in the past has led to
kind of consolidation and sort of larger
State spaces internal spaces precisely
because there's been conflict those
conflicts have happened they've been
solved in favor of one side or the other
that's led to a larger State and then
there's kind of a piece within that
state which in some cases might be more
beneficial on the other hand people are
of course also pointing out that having
offense dominant Technologies may lead
to more conflict and and that's and
that's on the on the negative side so um
yes I think I think it's a you know it's
sort of a contested and fraud area it's
it's one that within the social sciences
was much more active some decades ago
not not
um that active these days but I think
it's it's still sort of interesting to
think about I think productive and
fruitful you dare to make any best
guesses about what we really want to
know which is how you know is is AI as a
whole more uh does it lend itself better
to offense than to defense for example
the first thing to say is that we don't
know we don't know exactly uh how this
is going to go and how the technology is
going to develop but if I had to guess
I would say so the question is can AI
defend us against AI
I would say
very speculatively
um Not Without Really interfering with
privacy
so
probably unless we're willing to change
some
societal parameters like how invasive
the state is in our lives
add a guess we we actually won't be able
to use AI without doing that
we won't be able to use AI to defend
against
the sorts of offense dominant things
that AI will enable but as I say it's
really hard to say for sure or with any
certainty at all and here you might be
thinking of for example continually
scanning what software is running on on
people's computers to prevent them from
running uh dangerous AI exactly scanning
what everybody's doing maybe at some
point in the future what everybody's
thinking you know all these things so
without without becoming uh very
invasive emerging on totalitarian we
can't really AI is is often dominant you
would say no I I wouldn't put it that
strongly I I think you know that this is
very very speculative uh and I I think
that that's uh a sort of a guess but I I
wouldn't put a lot of credence in that
particular guess maybe we could move on
to the next uh your next kind of crucial
question and this this one is a bit
complex it's it's about thinking about
the failure rate of a technology in this
case Ai and relative to to kind of the
risk of that technology and here we're
thinking about International agreements
so
press a starting point is to talk about
the downsides of having a say an
international treaty that allow that
does not allow countries to have any
failures with the technology so just
imagine that that you uh yeah what are
the downsides of presenting a document
like that and trying to get people to
sign it yeah I think one way to to get a
handle on this is is maybe to think
about again to think about the nuclear
analogy and to think about two different
cases so you know one of the things that
we have are or have had are agreements
on the number of deployed nuclear
nuclear weapons that the US and Russia
can can have and at some point it was
four thousand and then it went to 1550.
so that so that's an agreement and then
the question is well what would the
world look like how different would it
be if one of the sides were to cheat on
this agreement you know suppose one side
built an extra 10 nuclear weapons
would that change the balance of power
no not very much right not very much the
sides have supposedly secure second
strike
and so building a few more nuclear
weapons uh isn't really fundamentally
changing strategic parameters probably
now contrast that case to the case where
we have a worldwide worldwide agreement
to ban nuclear weapons
so if there's zero nuclear weapons and
people have taken that idea seriously
there's been a lot of thinking about
exactly what a regime would look like to
get to zero nuclear weapons and they
concentrate on you know preventing any
individual state from breaking out
so-called and developing weapon what
could you do in order to prevent it uh
do something before they before they're
actually able to do it obviously if
you're in the world
of zero nuclear weapons one state
managing to build a few
probably has a huge effect on the
balance of power
so the sort of agreement that you would
need to design
in that kind of a world is very
different from the sort of agreement
that you need to design in the world
that we have where it's an agreement
just to limit to 1550 deployed nuclear
weapons and so that's the point that in
some cases you know we we just
can't really accept even a single
failure
and in other cases if the agreement
failed to some degree it wouldn't be
such a big deal and how we would design
institutions for the one case or the
other case is really very different do
you think we can allow failures with AI
I think it depends I mean it depends on
the the use case and the sort of risk
and I think in a lot of cases absolutely
uh you know we can we can allow a
certain degree of failure because
they're trade-offs right so you know we
shouldn't give up privacy rights to
prevent misuse of privacy rights for
instance that would be particularly
silly so I think there are areas where
we can accept a certain failure rate but
I think there are some areas too where
we where we get into the catastrophic
risk areas where probably we want the
failure rate to be very very very very
very low and I think that involves a
different sort of agreement yeah we can
talk about different Stakes for say an a
recommendation algorithm versus Under
that's on the one hand and then
potentially an energetic
superintelligent system way on the other
hand where some people would claim that
that with the with the smarter than
human a genetic system we we might we
might not be able to allow any failure
rate do you think do you think we could
succeed in in building
um agreements and and regulations that
involve no possibility of failure for
for each of the states it just depends I
mean I don't think we know all the
Strategic parameters
um so if we're in a world where you know
an answer to the the first first
question that we talked about is that AI
just can't defend against other
dangerous AI
all right just can't do it that's one of
the things that could suggest you really
need to have a kind of a zero failure
rate for instance
um and then can you actually do that
it's extremely difficult I think you
know again it depends on other you know
the sort of plausibility of it depends
on the answer to some other questions
so if it turns out for instance that the
things that give States let's say
military advantage
are the same things
or involve taking on more risk
of misaligned AI for instance
so in other words if risk taking
and augmenting Power
are throughout the course of
technological development or always kind
of wedded together
then that is not a very safe world and
will make it very hard to get an
agreement of the sort that that we would
need uh in that context and we haven't
really faced that before right because
with nuclear weapons you know again
closely related to the point we were
making a moment ago with nuclear weapons
there's decreasing marginal returns
probably of building another nuclear
weapon so at some point you know you you
can blow up the world I mean
people who study nuclear politics would
be upset at me for putting it in kind of
such a Cavalier way but let's just put
it in the way that you know makes sense
intuitive sense to all of us if you can
blow up the world three times then being
able to blow it up again you know once
or twice it's it's not doesn't really
change things that much so you have less
incentive once you have secure second
strike at any rate to to continue to to
invest in the technology but it may not
be like that with AI because it might be
the case that at each point you know you
can you can have very significant new
capabilities if you continue to invest
in the technology and so you have
continual incentive to do that and if in
addition to that continual incentive to
invest in the technology that's a
continual incentive to take uh extreme
risks of course that's a really bad
world and then if it turns out in
addition that we really need to have an
an agreement that has a zero failure
rate in that world because the
technology can't defend against itself
well that you know that that's not good
but maybe maybe uh maybe if we can't
settle this question we can move on to
the next one which is about verification
so we're talking about uh which
agreements governments could make and a
crucial Factor there is what one
government can verify about the actions
uh or the behaviors of of the other
government what options do we have
available for verifying whether states
are compliant with an agreement perhaps
we could we could talk about the nuclear
case and then maybe the the AI case yeah
sure so I mean in the in the nuclear
case you know as we've already said when
it comes to weapons actually being used
or even tested now we have uh technology
that is really quite reliable and in
detecting that and again this is a case
where because we have that information
we can have an agreement in which we
condition on that information and that
can be very helpful and that is what
facilitates things like mutually assured
destruction uh which supposedly is is
stabilizing and at least seems to have
helped us uh get through and and survive
when of course we should remember at the
beginning of the nuclear period many
many people thought that Humanity would
not survive Bertrand Russell wrote a
book uh the title of the book was a will
man survive
um and I think his his probable answer
was was no at that time ver the ability
to verify to have the information that
an adversary is actually complying with
an agreement can be extremely important
and this is also a technical challenge
was a technical challenge when it comes
to detecting nuclear tests
and it's a and it's a technical
challenge today when it comes to
detecting what what other actors are
doing with uh AI Technologies and but
it's not exclusively a technical matter
because it may be that you need to put
some things in place in an agreement in
order to facilitate verification so for
instance in the open Skies treaty that
that's a treaty where the sides are are
allowing overflights in order to see in
fact what each other are doing and they
use what's called National Technical
means in order to do that on the other
hand there's some agreements about what
can be covered up and what can't be
covered up in order to facilitate using
National Technical means so yeah so I
think you know we we need to sort of uh
have a a unified Technical and social
strategy here
um and we and we don't actually know
what sorts of verification techniques
we're going to be able to develop in
this area and what they will require and
how invasive the technical procedures
will be that go along with with these
techniques but that kind of question
because countries don't like revealing
what they're doing in their National
Security establishments so they're very
unwilling to do that so if it requires
really invasive techniques to verify
what another side is doing and that's a
problem
I'll just say one thing because maybe it
it to me it's a it's a hopeful point
it's a point that that others have made
but you know what what we need in a way
is something like a dog because when a
dog is sniffing uh a bag at an airport
it's able to detect okay is this a
dangerous thing but the nice thing about
the dog is that it doesn't give you
other information it just tells you this
one thing dangerous not dangerous but
doesn't tell you if the person is going
to Florida or is cheating on their
spouse or or anything like that and so
that's exactly what we need we need to
build that kind of sophisticated but not
too sophisticated and giving us more
information than than we actually want
so that it's acceptable to these
National Security establishments
yeah okay I get that so so do you have
any idea how a dog might work in in how
can we make a technical doc that tells
us exactly what what AI is is doing but
but uh in the in the in the enemies uh
companies but but no more
it's is there anything is there anything
promising on the technical side there
yeah that's a great question a difficult
question and a first thing I'll say is
that there probably are some others I
hope there are some others uh who can
give a better answer to it than than I
can uh maybe the first thing to say is
that probably we can have some Hardware
mechanisms on ships which allow us to
monitor exactly how those chips are
being used add a guess those sorts of
techniques will have to be combined with
data governance of some sort because
when training for instance is started on
on chips you might be asking yourself
well how much compute is embodied in
this training run but that's actually
hard to say if unless you know something
about this sort of starting point of the
of the training run which in part
related to the the data that's being
used so most likely
I think we're gonna need to have
both a sort of data governance and some
Hardware mechanisms in order to make
these ideas really work people have
started to flesh out what a general
scheme could look like but I think there
are many technical challenges that
remain I don't think we have or are
really close to having Technical
Solutions that we might might need for
this also just one thing that seems to
make it inherently difficult is is just
you can't really prove a negative it's
difficult to prove that you that you
don't have additional Computing Hardware
or additional nuclear warheads and so
that's that's that's always like the
challenge that's that's looming as I see
it yeah exactly I mean in the nuclear
area you know often there are agreements
and and also the chemical weapons area
uh their agreements to search declared
sites but what about the rest of the
space in the country obviously other
things could be happening there and yet
countries have not been willing to make
everything in their in their country
available to to search an examination
and so there's this kind of tension
there and whether we can have detection
techniques that are sufficient so that
they're willing to really trust that
their adversaries aren't violating
conventions but on the other hand don't
give adversaries so much information
that they are simply not willing to
enter into the agreement in the first
place I think that's the very severe
technical challenge that we face for mil
on the military side of governing AI
between the major powers
so as I say that's really hard we have
lots of opportunity to govern when it
comes to relations between other powers
that are really part of the security
environment that are created by the
major powers and also the whole civilian
space where I think also there are a lot
of risks that we need to deal with yeah
maybe maybe this flows nicely into your
your fourth crucial question which is
whether whether it's the case that a
small Club of Alliance States
can control the inputs into the
technology in this case AI so we're
talking about whether say the US and its
allies can control the supply chain of
computing hardware and potentially also
algorithms and and data what do you
think is the answer to this question as
it as it as it stands right now
well I listed this as a question that we
didn't know the answer to so it is hard
to answer it but
um but I I would just say that you know
I I think we we do know that the supply
chain is narrow and uh that a small Club
of line states can do quite a bit when
it comes to when it comes to controlling
access to the latest uh Computing
Technologies so so that much I think we
have a pretty good idea of what we don't
know is how long will that be the case
we don't really know yet because we
haven't seen specific regulation to deal
with cloud computing so we don't know
how well those things are going to work
and we don't know what risks
are associated with existing compute and
non-frontier compute or perhaps you know
one generation old uh compute something
like that so that's what we really don't
know the answer to
I think many people are really hopeful
that the scaling hypothesis will will
hold and that it will turn out that um
that really Advanced forms of AI need
absolutely enormous amounts of compute
so enormous that controlling just The
Cutting Edge is sufficient you know
people have different intuitions about
this some people have you know more
finely calibrated intuitions that than I
do but that's just not my intuition I
don't believe it I think that uh older
generations of of compute you know if
you're really willing to maybe spend a
little bit more take a little bit more
time in order to to keep up uh that you
know yes it will require some Technical
Solutions yes interconnect speeds are a
big deal but nevertheless if you're
talking about really motivated actors
you know China likes to talk about two
bombs in the satellite that is in spite
of all the restrictions from the West on
developing a nuclear weapon and a
thermonuclear weapon and a satellite it
develo left two bombs in a satellite so
I'm not sure it will be you know people
are skeptical many people are skeptical
about recreating a chip supply chain
um or another chip supply chain in kind
of the medium term
and they may be well well be right about
that but on the other hand using
existing compute
and doing some mod some technical
modification in order to make that
existing compute work
you know again I don't know but
intuitively it seems to me like like
that's a source of risk yeah there's a
question here of how quickly you can you
can get from say the The Cutting Edge
system say The Cutting Edge system in in
2022 can you train such a system on much
cheaper Hardware in 2032 for example and
if that's the case then if we believe
that that today's systems are on the
verge of becoming dangerous then it
seems that the that we we can't really
control the the necessary ingredients
for AI for for a long time because at a
certain point with enough advance in
Computing hardware and so on uh training
these systems will be available
potentially even to individuals you you
can get different estimates of this but
I I don't think it's it's uh it's a bad
estimate to think that within 10 years
you would be able to train a system like
deep T4 on a on something that's
available to a rich individual exactly
and yet it also comes back to this first
question that we had can we actually use
advanced technology to to defend us
against these other advances in
technology and if we can so if it turns
out that you know whatever dangerous
thing you can do on your laptop can be
well defended against by the thing that
that the latest super computer can do in
10 years well that's like a much safer
world but we just don't know if that's
going to be the case do we have any so I
know you you mentioned this as an as an
open question but do you have any
leanings do you have any do we have any
indications from the world about how
this might turn out which world do you
think we are in I mean again you know
it's so much speculation I I sort of go
back to you know I think that
Technologies are going to become uh so
so capable that you know if we just kind
of project forward the world of today
with all the freedoms that we have today
and and and all the access to to the
information that we have today if we
just project forward that world but we
say that algorithmic progress uh has
happened for for 10 years something like
that then
I think probably you know individuals in
that world will be able to do some
things that we
will find hard to defend against uh in
in that world and and so you know at a
guess I think we're going to have to
make some choices about what individuals
have access to and and the ways that
they can can be monitored but I'm still
hopeful that we can do things like
create the dog that we were talking
about before so we monitor for certain
things but a whole range of other things
we we don't monitor for uh at all but I
think that this is going to occasion all
sorts of broad societal conversations
yeah one thing we talked about earlier
was this question of of hacking
um and cyber security at the top
companies and this is interesting in
this context also because even if we
have the 3DS and we have the
verification system and we know that for
example no training runs larger than X
or are occurring outside of uh of of
these companies you could imagine Rogue
groups or Rogue States uh hacking into
top companies and simply stealing the
model when you've when you've trained
the model it it doesn't take up that
much space and it's uh current Labs or
current companies do not have military
grade security yet and so this just
seems like a live opportunity that that
we might see leaks or hacks uh
getting these these models out there
available in the world does this does
this undermine all of this talk of the
treaties and agreements and verification
that we've talked about it's a great
question
um I guess for four points to make uh
the first is that you know I think you
hear this view in in DC uh where some
tech companies have said that they don't
want to work on military-grade things or
they don't want to work with militaries
and things like that and and the view of
some in the National Security
establishment is well actually what
they're doing is working with China and
everybody else but not working with the
US government because their systems are
compromised and and and they're hacked
by these other governments but but maybe
not by the US government or at least
that's the that's the perception that
that people have uh and so
um yeah and so and so why and so is that
really the right thing so I you know
without a doubt there's a need for
military grade uh as you have said uh
cyber security and even if you have it
it's just not clear that it really works
in the end that these systems can't be
stolen so I think two two points
um so one maybe just a tiny bit of a of
a tangent but you know you've been
asking about intuition so here here's
another intuition for you I I think that
we're coming back we're going to be
coming back to a world where some of the
advanced systems are really going to be
using more inference compute so so it'll
still be a tiny fraction of overall
training compute but but it but it will
there will be a sort of another
bottleneck when it comes to inference
compute and I think uh the Chain of
Thought reasoning is is probably an
example of that and and you know we were
talking earlier about how we don't
really know how how systems work but
probably we can build things on on top
of current systems that kind of make
them if you will think harder
um there used to be with Mathematica
there was a way you could say simplify
and then you could say another command
was simplify harder it was I always love
that like you were just telling it think
harder you know we're a little more yeah
and you can you can do this with current
language models too so you might say
think step by step through this problem
and and and your your argument here or
your conclusion from this would be that
these systems would begin using more
compute when they're running when
they're actually solving our problems
because of that yeah I I think that's
right and and really the the the reason
I draw that conclusion is is less these
sorts of specular things although I
think that's that's likely
um and more sort of what we're seeing in
the Strategic space because uh the
branching factor in in any
um sort of significantly complicated
social situation is such that just doing
all the training in advance uh for for
this strategic situation isn't very
effective and we see that in go you know
the the most advanced go playing systems
don't do that well unless they're kind
of thinking about okay what is the
Strategic situation on the board right
now what does that look like a few moves
ahead now that's not enough that that
was an enough for chess because chess
had this really simple heuristic for
understanding okay how good is the state
of the board for me at any point in time
but so you you need this these other uh
diffuse uh approaches to to AI that have
been so incredibly successful for
figuring out well is this a reasonably
good state for me or is this not a
reasonably good state for me for
something as complex as go on the other
hand you also need these compute
intensive things that is inference
compute intensive things uh to think
about okay what is the Strategic
situation in this particular context uh
that that some of these folks refer to
as as search and so I think
um you know it seems to me both sort of
based on kind of loose theory if you
will in my case and and sort of some
empirical evidence I should say from
these strategic systems that are being
developed in more complex multiplayer
non-zero-sum environments that that in
fact we're gonna in order to really be
more effective in those environments
we're going to need more inference
compute so I think again you know this
gets back to the question of what can
you do just with just by stealing a
system and having it on your PC or
something like that I think we're going
to be in a world where in order to be
most effective in strategic contexts we
need more inference compute again it's
not really my my direct area of
expertise I mean I uh game theory has
been a long time interest of mine but on
the compute side I think it's more
speculative but that's the way it seems
to me okay so there's a little bit of a
digression but now I want to get back to
your specific question which I actually
think sort of
um I probably would answer in in sort of
the opposite way uh from from what you
had suggested
um so do we need International
governance given that these systems can
be stolen
I would say yes we we need it precisely
because the systems can be stolen in
some sense because we need to worry also
about the development stage you know if
the systems can be stolen and if the and
then they can be easily used if that's
true
well then we need to also have things
like licensing back at the development
stage
and if we're going to do that
internationally that means some sort of
international regime to to make that
happen
um I don't I don't um you know I guess
the the point about copying you know it
sort of leads me in the opposite
direction that we need more and at
earlier stages of the technology life
cycle might this be easier to implement
uh as an agreement between states it
seems that that each state would be
interested in in the companies in that
state having excellent cyber security
because then then they're they're kind
of very important and valuable perhaps
even militarily valuable Secrets
wouldn't be stolen so it's just
intuitively it seems like it would be
something that would be easier to sign
up for for States absolutely I think um
I think cyber security you would think
would be something they could sign up
for I think it's possible that there's
some trade-offs in terms of uh you know
Effectiveness in the company so I think
in some cases you know really
significant cyber security has cost to
people who are working in the company
you know they have to suddenly start
doing things in Secure rooms and all
sorts of things I mean you know a friend
of mine who's working at the defense
department he he has a really hard time
picking up his kids after school because
he tends to work late and if he picks up
his kids that means he has to leave the
secured environment go back to the
secure environment and that takes a lot
of time
and um and the result is that it's hard
to pick up your kids so they're very
practical uh things that go along with
with these sorts of security measures
but I agree with you that from the point
of view of of a state uh these things
might be uh desirable okay I I think we
should talk about so we've been talking
about various problems and various
opportunities for for how we might
regulate Ai and I think we should get to
your more specific proposal for how we
might do this which which you've kind of
sketched out in in three parts uh which
consists of a international body that's
that sets standards for for AI and then
this uh jurisdictional certification
body which you you might explain what
that means and then an implementation
using kind of national or domestic laws
potentially you could you could talk
about how the system might work and and
what the advantages of setting up AI
governance like this would be great this
is relates to a white paper that I've
been working on and and with with a
whole host of other folks I think 12
people are on the paper so so credit uh
certainly to to many others yeah so uh
we what we do in this paper is sketch
out an approach to International
civilian AI governance and as as I think
we've sort of now covered we think that
civilian governance is maybe they're
just it's more potential in the near
term for for doing things there
um but even though we're talking about
civilian governance there's still a
security aspect to things so one thing
you might ask yourself is is a security
apparatus in the United States going to
allow an international organization to
enter the offices of open Ai and see
everything they're doing and how they're
training things and even if they did
would you actually want that because of
the proliferation implications I mean
the iaea is sort of conventionally
believed to have all sorts of spies in
it for instance not that it gets to go
into the National Security
establishments of the club of nuclear
Powers but it goes into everybody else's
what they're doing in the nuclear area
so you know so that was one of the sort
of motivational ideas for the framework
that that we developed we we thought
probably the answer was no it wouldn't
be allowed you wouldn't actually want it
so what else could we do in order to
regulate civilian Ai and so we're
interested in something that we think is
kind of similar to some of the other
regimes that are out there for instance
International civilian Aviation
organization the international Maritime
organization and financial activities
task force or the are the three that we
look at primarily but I think in in some
other areas too and what all three of
these have in common is that they are
not auditing firms within countries they
are auditing jurisdictions to see if
those jurisdictions have the appropriate
regulation and in some cases to see if
they're actually enforcing the right
regulation and so that's the approach
that we've also taken here and and we
call it jurisdictional certification and
so the idea so our sort of suggestion is
that you have an international
organization that has talked to
everybody all of the other standards
organizations domestic standards
organizations and and experts around the
world and has consensus on a kind of
minimal set of international
standards that that globally we think
should be applied everywhere and again
that's not every standard right we
jurisdictions should be able to have
different laws on lots and lots of
things when it comes to regulating AI
but once they've agreed on on a minimal
set of standards they can audit the
jurisdictions to see if they're actually
putting those into law and are effective
at making those standards a reality in
terms of outcomes and so any
International regime needs some some
teeth and you might say some reasons for
for compliance and our idea is well we
could tie this certification to the
trade regime in two ways both in terms
of imports and in terms of exports and
this relates a little bit to What's Done
in some of these other areas so you know
in the case of AI what you might say is
so countries around the world might say
well we're not going to import any AI
technology
that
uses
AI from a jurisdiction that doesn't have
certification from this International
standard setting organization I think
that would provide really quite a strong
incentive for uh for firms within those
jurisdictions to pressure their own
jurisdictions to uh to adopt the
international standards and that's
exactly what we see for instance the the
effect of the financial action task
force appears to be that when it puts a
jurisdiction so it actually has what's
called a black and a gray list and when
it puts a jurisdiction on one of those
lists it tends to raise costs for
financial institutions within that
jurisdiction and they in turn put
pressure on their own jurisdictions to
to get off those lists so you can
imagine something similar happening or
similarly in the case of
um of Iko the international civilian
Aviation organization the FAA in the
United States has the ability to prevent
flights entering U.S airspace from any
jurisdiction that doesn't that is in
violation of Iko
rules and standards so again there's
sort of similar things that are that are
already going on in in these
organizations that we think that we
think we can withdraw from when it comes
to Ai and similarly on the export side
countries could say in a kind of
multilateral export regime way that
they're not going to export the inputs
into AI Technologies to jurisdictions
that don't have certification from the
international standard setting
organization so that's sort of how we
think it could could work and as I say I
don't think it solves all problems uh
but it's it's sort of an interesting to
us an interesting
potential uh institutional model to
consider yeah and you could see a
situation say that uh one country say
that Denmark refuses to sign this to
sign up for this uh for these standards
well then per potentially AI companies
within Denmark would pressure the
government to to sign up for the
standards so they could export their
products earn money on the international
market so you could see the the
incentives turning the other way as both
to the the incentives of the Danish
government and the Danish AI companies
being aligned in the sense that they
want to push ahead of as quickly as
possible and they don't want they don't
want to be regulated in any way there
would now be some form of incentives for
uh for signing up for for these
standards so I I it's a it's an
interesting proposal I think oh that's
great because we uh you know we're
trying to build support for one person
at a time so we we're really we're
really glad to have you on board
absolutely I think we we should run
through a list of objections to to the
whole project of of AI governance the
the kind of common theme here is just
skepticism about the motives of the
institutions or the actors involved if
we if we start with with the governments
involved maybe maybe we set up an
international organization and we use
this organization to monitor different
AI companies in different countries
couldn't one government simply gain
information about what what what
companies in other countries are doing
and use that information to Advantage
their own AI capabilities so pretend you
could see the the monitoring process
involving gaining information that would
be useful for for increasing your own AI
progress absolutely I think that's
really the right worry to have and and I
think that the frontier AI States will
have exactly that worry and so we really
need to to consider it if if we're going
to get buy-in from some of those key key
actors on the other hand I I guess I
would say that
um you know if we feel like we want some
form of international AI governance the
version where you have an international
organization that's actually looking at
firms that seems to have that
proliferation aspect in a much much
stronger sort of sense
um whereas so I think the main
proliferation aspect when it when it
comes comes to the kind of if you will
Ico model that that we've proposed or
jurisdictional certification model that
that we've proposed is when it comes to
knowledge that the regulator would need
in order to set standards and yes I
think that it's entirely possible that
um that the regular would need to know
things that some countries around the
world would would consider harmful forms
of proliferation but I think we
shouldn't sort of assume that that's
always the case I think it's likely to
be the case sometimes for some standards
but isn't sort of broadly across the
board likely likely to be the case and I
think there are some models also for for
sort of dealing with the kinds of
sensitive information that for instance
a government or a firm might communicate
to the international organization so one
model for instance is is the iaea after
it decided that it was going to take
information from State intelligence
Services a few decades ago it had
previously had thought no no that is
dangerous to do that because then things
could be revealed selectively for
political gain and that would be a bad
thing but then it realized well there's
a lot of things we don't know that
intelligence services do know so we want
to be able to take on some of that
information and it adopted a set of
rules and approaches to taking on that
information and and trying to really
keep it keep it secret so for instance
states have the ability to go and talk
to the general director directly and I
think one other person in a room if they
if they don't want to reveal information
to others I think that there will be
that the specifics here will be very
consequential and important but I
wouldn't I wouldn't sort of rule out the
approach in advance because I think we
have models of it in other context and I
think you know there are ways of kind of
mitigating hopefully if not fully some
of the issues there's even more
skepticism about the motives of the
governments involved here uh you might
you might say different governments have
have their own motives and they they
might pretend to care about AI safety
but really they care about say National
Power and specifically the Power Balance
between them and another country the U.S
might think let's try to slow down China
by implementing some some safety
measures in China might think let's try
to catch up to the U.S by implementing
safety measures how do we know whether
the I mean in some sense this is a fully
General problem that's that we can't
really solve but do we
how can we assess whether governments
are being sincere in in their efforts to
to regulate AI yeah I mean I think
that's a great question I think you're
absolutely right that we shouldn't
expect you know we talked about zero
failure rates and and I don't think this
is necessarily a model with a zero
failure rate I don't I think it it
ameliorates some issues but um if the
civilian actors uh you know we think
they have incentive to do things that uh
even one failure is uh catastrophic then
probably we we need to accordion sort of
we need to expand uh what the
international regime is is doing but I
just don't see a a potential for
expanding it too much right now uh in
the future it's possible that there be
more appetite uh for for that sort of
thing yeah so maybe it's also worth just
mentioning that you know sort of
allowing enforcement to happen at the
domestic level at least enforcement on
firms to happen at the domestic level as
opposed to uh the sort of incentives on
jurisdictions is I think important here
because there's less sort of trust if
you will that's required going in so I
think you know these sorts of concerns
about okay maybe this other jurisdiction
won't be doing X or Y are first of all
more live in the security space than
they are in the civilian space but they
exist also in the civilian space on the
other hand if you're allowing the
enforcement to happen at the domestic
level then that gives more flexibility
to to domestic regulators and and to the
domestic government as a whole if they
actually do feel like regulations are
specifically targeting them and they're
having a sort of negative effect on
their International Security they would
have the ability to uh to simply not not
enforce them now that could then have
implications in terms of international
markets but maybe that would be a kind
of way to strike the balance between not
so scary the regulations from the point
of view of regulators and countries that
they're not willing to enter into the
agreement in the first place but also
significant enough that they would have
incentives for compliance but you know
this is all out of hope I think we're
still trying to figure out what the best
approaches to International governance
are and I mean there's also the question
of how some people have been looking at
their own country's AI companies they
come to the to the international
governance organization and they say we
we have this data we have we've we've
found out these things how do you know
whether you can trust them and how do
how do the other countries that are
members of the standard setting body
know whether they can trust the
information coming from a domestic
regulators and here we might this maybe
ties back to the question of
verification that we talked about maybe
there's some way to present something
that's objective that can't be tampered
with that has some some form of
technical solution where you could
present something that's uh that can be
proven to to be uh to be true
information so that's a great question
uh you can we can look to some of the
models that we have from some of these
other regimes and in other Industries uh
so uh the
um Financial activities task force has
the ability to request uh all sorts of
information from uh jurisdictions and
jurisdictions under the regime are
obligated to comply with it so there
again is this balancing question of what
sorts of information would they be able
to request and would it be proliferating
and that would have to all be be worked
out that that would be sort of the
details of of the monitoring but
probably uh you know there would be a
set of variables that they could ask
about that countries would be required
to to disclose and that would provide
some love level of monitoring and then
there might also be just like in the
case of the iaea there might be all
sorts of monitoring that let's say
National Intelligence services are also
doing and they could provide further
information just like they do to the
iaea they could provide further
information to uh to the proposed
international organization in this
context
so there's other sorts of information
that
you can make credible by giving the the
sort of the backup you know again just
similar to you know if you're presenting
intelligence information you might
disclose your sources or you might not
and similarly here if you're saying well
you know maybe it's information that you
have about an algorithmic advancement
and and you know that um that actually
the the rate of algorithmic progress has
shot up and so that implies a different
sort of Regulation or maybe a different
sort of bar for for what
um sorts of systems uh require licensing
or something like that and you you could
say well we think that um that actually
we need scrutiny of smaller systems than
we did before because of this change and
what we Now understand about algorithm
excuse me algorithmic progress
so that's a possibility and maybe that
would be credible and maybe it wouldn't
because maybe that would seem like
putting up some sort of barrier to some
other actor or something like that but
maybe in order to make it credible a
country could say well here's the
evidence here here's what you do you
know and of course there'll be a
trade-off there they wouldn't
necessarily want to do that perhaps that
could be proliferating
um so you know there'd be I think you
know some trade-offs to be to be weighed
and you know exactly how they do that I
think would be Case by case but you know
certainly a set of difficult problems
there's also a skepticism about the
motives of the companies involved so so
right now we have the the top AI
companies in the US
being basically calling for regulation
and and being kind of open to regulation
we discussed earlier whether this is
this is an attempt to front run the
process to to make sure that you don't
get that they don't get regulations that
they they that they consider too strict
basically but another interpretation
that I've heard is that this is this is
a an attempt to capture the the whole
regulatory process and make sure that
that the the rules are favorable to them
and potentially are disfavorable to
their uh uh competitors you could you
could see how it might be in their
interest to set up a system of rules
that are difficult and expensive to
comply with such that new AI startups
can't afford the the legal burden of
complying with these rules and that they
kind of cement their their market
dominance
I think these are exactly the right
questions to ask I think we should have
these suspicions of Industry all the
time and I think we should be wary of
um centralizing uh economic power in a
small set of companies I think these are
I think they're real costs to doing that
and um and so I think it's it's the
right set of questions but I sort of
want to say that you know even paranoids
have enemies uh that is uh you know even
if there might be
um some some downsides here there's also
some potentially reasons to to think
about some of these regulations
um and people have been really concerned
about Licensing in this way the
regulatory burden of Licensing would be
would be onerous and and I think that's
the right question to ask on the other
hand you know ultimately we probably
want for some uh for some systems we
want kind of go no-go decisions just
like we have for buildings can you build
a building well you know it's got to
stand up right and and even you know
before you get to build it uh you know
you have to go through all sorts of
engineering sign offs and other
sign-offs are there Financial costs to
that yes there are Financial costs to
that
um but we we think it's a good idea and
and we still we still think that um that
we should should have those things I I
think somewhat more speculatively I'm a
little skeptical that the regulatory
burden would be
um the kind of major hurdle that would
be making it hard for smaller players to
to get in into things
um I mean if certainly if we're talking
about training systems from scratch uh
there are you know the the cost of
training a model I think are going
through a billion a billion dollars to
train The Cutting Edge llm so you know
that's a pretty significant hurdle right
there
um I sure hope that the regulatory costs
are are less than a billion dollars but
but you know again I think you know
these sorts of issues around
centralizing power are really important
ones I'm glad people are raising them
yeah and maybe uh just a final worry
here this is skepticism about again the
the the whole project of of AI
governance but this the worry is that we
will over regulate basically so this
this is about whether we will slow down
AI progress in a way that that we might
when we look back on it uh have wanted
that we didn't do so AI could we've all
heard about these these kind of
projections we could see a revolution in
medicine we could see a revolution in
how many Industries function and we
could see incredible kind of the
productivity gains that could help all
of us and so how do we avoid turning AI
into uh what happened with nuclear power
where it is now kind of so regulated
that it's very difficult to build a new
power plant even though nuclear power is
pretty safe compared to to other other
forms of of energy generation basically
the question is how do we regulate in a
smart way in which we avoid over
regulation I think we have to be aware
that this is a danger you know we have
to be be careful of it all around I
think if we are adopting regulation and
it looks as you if it looks as you
describe the nuclear power industry then
that's a real worry but
I don't think we're there or near there
right now I think it's it's unlikely
that we will get all the way there given
the sensitivity to exactly this issue in
governments around the world and I think
just a broader point about technological
progress I I don't think it's
controversial to say that it seems to be
speeding up not that it necessarily is
but I think it it seems that way and it
seems like there are some drivers of it
continuing to speed up people have
noticed I mean Rachel Carson said the
problem in the modern world is there is
no time that is no time to develop
appropriate regulations so if we gave
ourselves a little more time to figure
things out I think that would have also
some benefits in addition to the real
costs that you point out fantastic
Robert thanks for coming on it's been
super interesting for me oh thank you
Gus thanks for chatting I really
appreciate it